at what point did you say i'm not in the
mood to make another film
knowing how things are knowing some of
the battles that i might face with the
next one
but i have another idea um in
so we finished shooting like the water
in august of 2011
and we went immediately into post
i wish actually we had taken a little
bit of a breather and kind of
you know checked back in with because
the editing process you always get lost
in the forest for the trees
and while the director was in the
editing room and she was quite lost in
the forest for the trees i was out
trying to figure out what were the next
steps
for the film i went to afm for the first
time
which is my least favorite place on the
planet
and i'm going to get in trouble for
saying that but whatever
but sometime around when i started
learning about
how you have a film you get it into a
festival
usually because a sales agent has helped
you or you know the sales agent picks
you up at the festival and the sales
agent
helps you sell it to a distributor and
the distributor helps you package it
and well actually spends your money to
package it for the exhibitor and market
it to an audience and then the exhibitor
collects the money that your audience
spends on your movie and they take a cut
and the distributor takes a cut plus
everything that they spent to
do all that stuff and then the sales
agent takes a cut and by the time it
gets back to you there's no money left
none i mean i have friends who had films
get picked up
at sundance by the distributors that you
hope to get picked up by
and they made zero dollars on it and i
was like well
that's not sustainable like for whom is
that sustainable
um so that was really the point that i
thought
well there's an interesting thing that
happened when
we made like the water which was we knew
because we weren't going to get
traditional
financing that we had to reach out to
our community
and we reached out to them with a clear
story and the first part of that story
was
here's why we think we need to make this
movie now
and what it means to us personally to do
this
and two actually three things two
what we think it might mean to women
filmmakers to women in general
to um to the representation better
representation in film
and then the third piece was and here is
every specific thing
we need to make this movie and what
happened was when we went out with this
list we call it the original wish list
um which was just a list that we typed
into our wordpress website we put a
little paypal link in the bottom
um when people could see exactly
what their contribution to the film was
the car rental the sunscreen the bug
spray which was really
important if you're shooting in maine in
the summer get bug spray
people tended to contribute more than we
had thought
and then they started loaning us stuff
we hadn't considered
and they started loaning us locations
and goods and services that we didn't
think we could get and they took our
tiny little you know 85
000 movie and made it look much bigger
and much fancier i mean
we look for the locations that were
loaned to us like a 5 million
movie and those were all loaned to us it
made our film better because we had this
early interaction with our audience
and then as we continued into the
festival circuit
no matter where our film screened
anywhere in the world
and i'm including oaxaca and romania and
memphis was it memphis tennessee no
somewhere in mississippi
and obviously in maine where we shot it
somebody
who contributed to that campaign or
somebody who knew somebody who did
showed up and when we did screenings for
our community we had lines down the
block and around the corner we could
sell out a 350 seat theater
and this is for a tiny independent drama
about grief
starring only women mostly unknown
actors
right and so at that moment when i saw
kind of the the wreckage of the business
model that indie filmmakers
even in the best case scenario were
being promised
and this incredible investment from the
audience that was created out of this
wish list model
um and this was at the end of 2011 i was
like maybe we could
maybe there's something in there and
that's when i really started exploring
it and it was another sort of six months
until it was fully ideated
as this sort of one-stop shop
crowdfunding and distribution and
obviously in the last two years
we have iterated on the idea quite a bit
because we've gotten
so much feedback from the community and
they've been so incredibly vocal about
no
no this is the next thing we need and
we're like okay we'll try to get you
that you know
you